hopefully
week three for us ends up going better
than week three went for the nfl at
least the aftermath of week three
because that's when a week ago today all
hell broke loose as far as the pandemic
was concerned right after it looked like
everything was fine they'd cracked the
code on covet 19. we found out about the
titans outbreak that continued that drip
drip of positives from
the game that they played against the
vikings week three all the way through
the weekend no positive tests though for
the second straight day for the
tennessee titans which means if that
holds for just one more day
they can go back to the facility the
nine players who tested positive
expected to not be available wednesday
or for the remainder of the week now if
you're asymptomatic for at least five
days and then you have two negative
tests you can come back so maybe some of
these guys will start to to work their
way back in
but you know this is one of the things
we expected all along at some point
there would be teams down
more than a few guys because of covet 19
and we didn't expect teams to be shut
down for a full week or longer but
that's where the titans are and sharing
this comes just in time because they've
missed one game
they got to start getting ready for the
next game and the buffalo bills are
coming to town so if they can get back
in the building tomorrow and start
practicing and implementing the game
plan that they have ready for buffalo
then maybe the titans will have a chance
to
to make things go as well as they did
the day they played the buffalo bills in
the music city miracle game
that's taken us way back mike um yeah
mike frable said he gets the the results
of that day's covet test at 4 30 a.m so
he's gonna be up at 4 30 a.m in the
morning checking if there's no
positive test and they're crossing their
fingers that there's no more positive
tests they can reopen their building but
what a screwy week it's been for the
titans and and if they have a positive
test it's going to continue to be screwy
but as it stands he said he didn't
expect any of those guys on the coveted
list to play on sunday and they're going
to bring up guys from the practice squad
he said he's excited to see those guys
play things they can put
48 capable players out there dress them
and and get them out there and play and
so it is going to be weird it's going to
be a weird game for them it's been a
weird week for them obviously haven't
been on the practice field for a while
now
but as you have pointed out many many
times when you allow this to come into
your building you play pay a price for
it and there is an investigation looking
at how all this went down and how it
started and spread like it did because
other teams need to know
why and how this spread to try to
prevent it in their buildings and and so
the titans are paying that price i mike
frable has a very positive attitude
that's a good thing about it and i know
coaches are big on we can only control
what we can control and this is
something that's completely out of their
control
but they'll have to go forward and
hopefully get to play on sunday
strange to use the term positive
attitude when we're hoping that there
won't be any positive test results but
you know a couple of things that you
said that i want to flag the fact that
the titans get their results from the
prior days pcr samples that get off sent
off site for testing at 4 30 in the
morning the next day
that underscores the reality that how
close you are to one of these laboratory
facilities
determines when you get your results
some teams get them the same night some
teams get them 24 hours later the titans
are kind of in between where they they
find out at 4 30 in the morning but it's
all about getting the samples there once
they're there it only takes a few hours
to turn them around and you'd think
they'd be expediting the titan samples
given the fact that they're on
heightened alert that
the results are more likely to be
positive which is negative for the
titans but
that's what it is and that's what they
have to wait until tomorrow morning
early to find out and the idea that they
let it in their building you know the
nfl accepts it's getting in
the question is can you keep it from
spreading that's the the message now
it's inevitable that it's going to get
in unless and until there's a bubble for
each team in each city where you keep
players from going home
once players coaches and other essential
personnel leave the facility
they all have their own story they all
have their own set of facts they all
have their own circumstances pursuant to
which they may end up being exposed to
the virus the challenge is
when one
comes up positive
we want to make sure nobody else gets it
from that one that's what the nfl is
trying to do i don't know how practical
it is
but that's sharing what they're trying
to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports